The hatchet has been buried, and this "Fast
and Furious" cast member is roaring back into
the race.
Dwayne Johnson is set to headline his very
own "Fast and Furious" film.
Audiences for "Fast X" were delighted to find
out that the film's mid-credits scene features
the return of Luke Hobbs.
This brief cameo came after Johnson publically
made it clear that he wouldn't be returning
to the billion-dollar franchise.
Now, The Hollywood Reporter confirms that
Johnson is on track to return for a brand
new "Fast" project, which will center Hobbs
and various other "Furious" characters.
"Why do I smell baby oil?"
"You keep running your pie hole, you're gonna
smell an ass-kicking."
The outlet notes that this isn't a sequel
to 2019's "Hobbs and Shaw," the first spin-off
in the "Fast" franchise.
The Johnson-led project also isn't "Fast 11,"
which Louis Leterrier is expected to direct.
Instead, insiders are describing it as "Fast
X.5."
Is it an entry set directly after the events
of "Fast X," which saw the Fast Fam going
up against their number one hater Dante Reyes?
Or is Johnson's latest "Furious" adventure
set to detail the operation he was leading
at the end of "Fast X"?
Only time will tell what Johnson and company
have in store for fans.
One thing is certain: a core member of the
Fast family won't be showing up.
While other actors from the franchise are
set to reprise their roles for Johnson's film,
the Hollywood Reporter says that Dominic Toretto
actor Vin Diesel won't be popping up.
Diehard fans of the franchise will know that
Johnson and Diesel haven't been on the best
terms, which was one of the reasons why Johnson
was ready to leave Hobbs behind him and move on.
Despite their public feud, Leterrier says
he helped convince Johnson to return to the
franchise with the "Fast X" mid-credits scene.
This time, it seems like Johnson and Diesel
have really moved on, ready to bring the Fast
Fam together.
Johnson said in a lengthy tweet following
the film's announcement,
"Last summer Vin and I put all the past behind
us.
We'll lead with brotherhood and resolve – and
always take care of the franchise, characters
& FANS that we love."
"Wasn't half bad having you work for me."
[laughs]  "We all know you were working for me,
Hobbs."
What compelled Johnson to return to the franchise?
In a video accompanying the tweet, Johnson
says that fan reactions to the character's
return made him realize it was time to return
to the franchise.
"You don't turn your back on family.
Even if they do."
In his tweet, Dwayne Johnson teased that his
"Hobbs" movie, quote, "will serve as a fresh,
new chapter & set up for 'FASTX: Part II.'"
Will this "fresh, new chapter" include an
appearance by Dante, who has a vendetta against Hobbs?
While Johnson doesn't explicitly confirm Momoa's
return, he does say that, quote, "business
is about to pick up" between the two.
"Daddy's gotta go to work."
Ultimately, concrete details are slim on this
so-called "Fast X.5," though a writer has
been found in franchise OG Chris Morgan.
He's best known for penning some of the franchise's
most memorable films, including "Fast Five"
and "Tokyo Drift."
Morgan also brought the "Hobbs & Shaw" spin-off
to life, though he didn't return for "F9"
and "Fast X."
Some diehard "Fast" fans believe that Morgan
is the secret sauce to the franchise's success,
so it's definitely exciting to see the screenwriter
return to the series.
Johnson will also be producing his upcoming
"Fast and Furious" romp alongside Morgan.
What's surprising is that they've found a
producing partner in Vin Diesel, signaling
that their feud has genuinely come to an end.
That said, details are fairly scarce at the
moment.
A director isn't currently attached to the
project, and, according to Diesel, "Fast 11"
is set to race into cinemas in 2025.
It remains to be seen if the Hobbs-centered
film will be released before that.